the Joe Rogan experience well what else
can people do in terms of all this hand
sanitizer jazz and masks is that all
yeah the hand sanitizers actually are a
great thing for stopping a lot of
infectious diseases they actually are
really good they're good for your hands
you know in terms of the skin they kill
the bad bugs but the whole issue of
using your hands touching your face of
people all concentrate on yes the data
is actually very weak that this what
kind of virus is going to be transmitted
that way so I wouldn't tell you to stop
using hand sanitizers but don't think
it's gonna have a big impact on this
book did you see that viral video that's
going around that woman who was giving
the address at the behest of the White
House and she see that she tells people
not to touch their face and then
immediately licks her finger and I did
saw Paige yeah I saw that I saw that
well why is she telling people not to
touch their faces because you know well
the the thought was is that there are
receptors around your eye right here
that actually for this virus could get
in and then get into your body and you
know the data we have on this is so
sparse to say that that's the case I
think the primary thing about hand
washing is legitimate but one of the
things we want people want to do
something they want to be able to fact
they're doing something and so we tell
them wash your hands often and to
present this to prevent this disease and
I feel like we're not being really
honest with the people that the data and
and we've looked at this very carefully
really is about just breathing air and
that's a hard thing to stop so keep
doing the hand washing but don't think
that that's going to stop this disease
which you asked about the man to stop
other stuff yes yeah asks there's two
kinds right basically the surgical mask
which just fits over and the reason it's
called a surgical mask is because it's
loose-fitting just fits you know kind of
ties behind you because we're worn by
surgeons so that they don't cough or
drip into your wound and it was never
made to protect you from bugs coming in
so those little spaces on the sides
that's not a problem if I'm breathing
into the cloth right in front of my nose
but in terms of the air coming in on the
side they're not they're not effective
at all so people wear them they look
like they're doing something they're not
now if you are sick they may help a
little bit from you
transmitting because if you cough then
you coffee right into that cloth and
it'll some little embed in there or not
get out around the other one though is
called an in 95 respirator but for all
intents person looks like a mask it's
just tight face fitting it has the seal
you know the nose etc that's an
apocalypse mask it could be I don't know
what those are but that's good yes I'm
just saying that that's how I look at it
okay okay well they're actually we use
them all the time in health care all the
time and they use them in action about
90% of them are used in industry so
there are grinding things or asbestos
etc you know they don't breathe in all
these parts so if we have one of those
that'll do something they're very
effective they're very picked - the
problem is we have a big shortage you
know right now we have hospitals that
are down to just a couple days worth of
these masks those respirators and it's
because we don't stockpile anything in
this country you know we don't have
hospitals don't have the money to do
that
those Preppers right now are so excited
yeah all the preppers across the guy I
knew it I knew the day would come yeah
well they are they are Ann teaches and
well you know but well this is really
important because how health care
workers go is how the country I think
we'll see we're going you know there
been over 4,000 health care workers in
China who are infected many of on their
job and a number of them died and if in
this country we have a real challenge
delivering health care because we're
overwhelmed and then we have health care
workers picking up the infection like we
talked about the group in Milan and we
don't have the protection for them I
really believe that's when the public
will say wait a minute what's going on
here and and that's where I think the
challenge so we really have to protect
our health care workers they are the
frontline people and and the biggest
problem we have is a lot of these cases
need intensive care medicine which we
only have a limited number of beds for
but this is really sophisticated
medicine so when one of those people get
infected a doctor and nurse work in
intensive care it's not like you just
took out another soldier you took out a
special forces person you just can't
bring somebody in from family practice
wherever and put them in there and so
we've got to protect these workers and
I'm really concerned that that's one of
the areas we've not done nobody
stockpiles we have no you know capacity
to make lots of them all
you know prior to this event the
hospital purchasing agent would go
online click a button send me 5,000 of
these no be there the next morning
[Applause]